what about you sorry if you could go  anywhere in the whole world where would  you go I always wanted to be part of  something bigger  I love that answer something that lasts  that means something something more  important than life yes  [Music]  it's written in  [Applause]  this if I had money I would only spend  it on things that were fun you know not  boring things like taxes I'm just going  for everyone to party forever  [Applause]  when I first moved to LA Signs and all  the doors said no actors or dogs allowed  I changed that  and now y'all ready for something  different  you know we have to do we have to  redefine the form map those dreams and  print them into history look up and say  Eureka I'm not alone  all right  I'm in so much trouble Manny  we have to live now  I do mean something  you thought this town needed you  it's the most magical place in the world  who wants to see me fight a snake  hell yeah